(man) The sharks are back
in an all-new season
of "Shark Tank,"
where hopeful entrepreneurs
from across the country
dream of a chance
to secure an investment
and gain powerful partners...
to start, grow,
or save their businesses.
If the sharks
hear a great idea,
they're ready to invest
using their own money...
an opportunity like
what I'm going to give you
is going to come
once in a lifetime.
And they'll fight each other
for a piece of the action.
I simply want to go to bed
richer than I woke up.
Let's hear
your bloodsucking offer.
But first, the entrepreneurs
must convince a shark
to invest the full amount
they're asking for,
or they'll walk away
with nothing.
We're making this up
as we go.
No kidding.
It's sink...
I wanna set you on fire
and float you out of the tank.
Or swim.
They don't look real.
All aboard!
(clank)
Whoo-Hoo! Whoo!
(laughter)
♪♪
Who are the sharks?
They're self-made millionaire
and billionaire investors
who are entrepreneurs
themselves.
Kevin O'Leary
is a venture capitalist
who turned a $10,000 loan
into a software business
worth $4.2 billion.
Lori Greiner,
the queen of qvc,
holds over a hundred patents
and has launched
over 300 products,
grossing over
a half a billion dollars
in retail sales.
Daymond John is a fashion mogul
and branding expert
who grew
his homemade clothing line
into the globally recognized
fashion brand Fubu.
Robert Herjavec, the son
of an immigrant factory worker,
is now a technology mogul
who sold
his first internet companies
for over $350 million.
And Mark Cuban,
notorious
billionaire entrepreneur
and the outspoken owner
of the Dallas Mavericks.
♪♪
First up are
Heather Murphy-Monteith
and Andy Hurwitz,
with the next hot thing
in dance clubs.
Hello.
I am Heather Murphy-Monteith.
And my name
is Andy Hurwitz.
We are here today to offer you
10% equity in our company
in exchange for $150,000.
We tour across the country
in a custom-fitted disco van,
throwing incredible parties
where the dance floors
are packed
and the music
is always bumping.
I'm sure you've been
to some amazing parties before,
but ours have the most love,
the most fun,
and the most energy,
mostly because of
our fabulous clientele.
(dance music playing)
(Lori laughs)
(Robert) aw!
Oh!
(Robert) Whoo!
(laughs)
(rhythmically)
Go, Griffin. Go, Griffin.
(Heather) Oh, yeah!
Let's go, Buddy!
Raise the roof!
Come on, guys.
♪♪
Thank you so much, guys!
Whoo!
High fives! High five!
Thanks, guys.
(laughs)
Baby loves disco
is a family dance party.
We feature real music
played by real deejays
at real nightclubs,
during the day.
Saturday afternoon
is the new Saturday night,
But right now
we need your help
to have this
underground dance sensation
turned
into a big-money operation.
So who wants to dance?
(Robert and Lori laugh)
So if I'm a family of four,
how much do I pay?
The price of popcorn
and a movie,
depending on your city.
If you're in Philly...
give me a number.
You're getting in
at $20 a head.
When you go to smaller towns,
the price might be
$12 or $15 a ticket.
So, Heather, these aren't
birthday parties that I'm...
no.
So you go, and it's an event,
and you advertise it
like anybody would anything.
It's a big event.
You're party promoters
for kids, basically?
That's right.
We have our club events,
which are
at real nightclubs.
And it's the biggest party
in town.
We triple-clean the venue
from top to bottom,
making sure
it's completely child-proof.
Then we set up
our signature activity zones.
We have hula-hoop heaven,
we have
a family photo booth,
a chill-out zone,
and we top it all off with
a full spread of healthy snacks,
unlimited juice boxes
for the kids,
and for the parents,
a cash bar
as long as
they're not driving.
How many people
are in attendance?
We average around 350.
That's pretty consistent.
350, and that's been
consistent throughout?
Yes.
Right, so--
(Robert) So how do I
find out about you?
When we started
seven years ago,
we spent zero dollars
on traditional advertising.
It's the power of moms.
Not only do we have
word-of-mouth
through social media,
we have hundreds of moms
across the country
that love to come on board
on our team and work with us.
How much money have you made
in the seven years?
We have grossed
$2,800,000 in 7 years...
Whoa.
With $2 million of that
being in the last 5.
Wow.
What about
the last 12 months,
and what about
the last one month?
This year is going to be
a $525,000 year.
Let me just set up
the big picture for a second--
we spent the first two years
building the brand,
spending more money
than we could make
to get it from east coast
to west coast.
We plant as an institution
in each of these cities.
I go, I fly out,
I hire a mom, I train a mom,
I train a crew.
At our biggest
U.S. domestic spread
of 33 cities,
we made $800,000,
but we were under by $20,000.
So you sold $800,000,
but you lost $20,000?
Yes.
This year, you think
you're gonna sell $500,000?
What we haven't spoken to
is our amazing sponsorship.
We have $425,000 alone
this year in sponsorship.
Wait, Wait, wait, wait.
So $425,000 of
your $525,000 in revenue
is from a sponsor?
We have to walk a fine line
between sales and sponsorship,
because we--our sponsors
are sponsoring us
to play for free.
Why would I ever do
a free event?
Kevin, hang on.
I'm still confused
what the business
has evolved to today.
While this was
all happening,
we were approached
by major publishers.
Penguin books said,
"can you put out some books--"
you're dancing
around the question.
Give me one advantage--
Let me be clear on this--
the answer is,
at baby loves disco,
we make money
from sponsorship,
from ticket sales,
and we make money
from merchandise.
Give me an event,
just one Saturday afternoon.
How much money do I make?
We make
between $1,500 and $3,000
on each individual event.
How much will
the sales be next year?
Next year, we're projecting
to make $750,000.
What amount will come
from the shows,
from sponsorship,
from the merchandise?
Well, merchandise
is a question mark,
but we project sponsorship
to be in the same league.
We don't see why not.
So you think you can
find other sponsors
that wanna market to moms?
It's easy. I mean,
you can imagine,
it's not that difficult
to find other partners.
I gotta tell you,
when I hear you saying "easily--
I can get a sponsor
for $300,000 easily"...
right.
It really undermines
your credibility with me,
because if it was that easy,
you'd have multiple sponsors.
There's more risk
in doing sponsorship deals...
yes.
Than selling ticket sales.
No, you guys--You guys
are missing the point.
The thing is, we were
doing this before sponsorship,
and we'll continue doing it
without.
(Kevin) I don't think
I'm missing anything.
Heather, how many parties can
you throw that sell tickets,
that allow you
to generate revenue?
That's how you can control
your own destiny, right?
Well, since we've been
through that experience,
and since we worked for three
years without sponsorship...
When you said you had
a network of moms everywhere
that you were working with,
that's enormous value.
When you started to tell me
about all these kids
you brought into these events
all the time,
I could see value in that.
When you started polluting it
with all the other stuff,
that ruined it.
I'm out.
But we've sunk into creative,
and we've built the brand,
and it's doing great.
But, Heather, Heather,
the challenge
that we're having here...
Yes?
Nobody said
you did a bad job,
nobody said
you didn't dedicate yourself.
We just don't understand
what's happening going forward.
I'm absolutely lost.
I'm out.
Honestly, we are
making this up as we go.
We have created
this brand--
No kidding.
You are making it up
as you go.
(laughs)
Think of it this way--
I'm just a simple investor
trying to scratch out
a living, okay?
Right.
He's right when he says
he's simple.
And I don't understand how
I could ever
make any money with you.
I don't understand
what you're doing.
I simply wanna go to bed
richer than I woke up.
That'll never happen
with you guys.
I am out.
I like what you're doing.
I like the premise of it.
Kids being happy and dancing
at good, healthy,
fun parties is great.
But I have to say,
I'm concerned
that the business model
isn't there,
and I'm--I just don't think
that I would make back
my money fast enough.
And for that reason,
I'm out.
Thank you.
Look, you--You built something
that nobody else could do.
You built a business with moms
to do shows to attract kids.
You grew the market,
and you stopped doing that.
In what way
did we stop doing it, though?
Our numbers of attendees
have increased.
We threw a 5,000-Person party
in central Park last year.
Look, I...
Andy, I-I gotta tell you,
I-I'm not buying
into the business plan. I'm out.
Good luck, guys.
Appreciate it.
Thank you, though.
Thank you.
Appreciate it.
(Lori) Good luck.
Ready, boss?
It's not
a horrible business.
You know what, though?
They're not salespeople.
But they just confused
the whole thing
by trying to tell us
they had so much going on.
What are we talking
about this for?
What's the point?
(laughs) Yeah. Right. Right.
It's over. We never
have to listen to that again.
Heather is a survivor.
I'm a survivor.
We are excited
to move forward.
And, you know,
it's a humbling experience.
Sometimes it feels good
to get your butt kicked
on national tv.
♪♪
(horse whinnies)
My name's Ryan Ehmann,
and I'm from Loveland, Colorado.
(girl) What's this one?
I live out here with my wife
and my 2-year-old son
and my 3 1/2-year-old daughter.
Whoo!
(laughs)
For 14 years,
I was a professional rodeo rider
on the pro rodeo circuit.
Ten years ago, I got injured
really bad at a rodeo.
I went to over 15 doctors,
and they said
I'd never ride again.
I was so determined to get
my health back and life back,
I got certified as a trainer
and healed my body.
Yeah! Two!
(class) whoo!
I've developed
a revolutionary workout program
that's better than
anything on the market.
(Ryan) We're galloping
the horse!
I just had this burning desire
that I needed to take
this unique workout
and help millions of other
people get their lives back.
Rodeo abs! Here we go!
I've taken my workout system
as far as you can
on a local level.
I need an investment
from the sharks
because I need an infomercial,
to where I can bring my passion
straight into people's homes,
bringin' the good old
cowboy energy,
and get you what you want,
which is results.
Whoo-Hoo! That's what
I'm talkin' about!
♪♪
Whoo-Hoo! Howdy, folks!
My name's Ryan "Cowboy" Ehmann,
and my company's called
lose 12 inches
with any 12 workouts.
I'm seeking
a $120,000 investment
for a 25% stake
in my life-changing company.
Sharks, everybody said I was
crazy to come into the tank.
Let me show you crazy.
Check this out.
Yep! That's me.
I was a rodeo rider
on the pro rodeo circuit.
I then started having
chronic lower back pain.
I went to over 15 doctors.
They said I'd never ride again
or never do anything physical,
and I'd have to live
with a "bad back."
I was so determined
to heal my back
and prove those doctors wrong,
I went and got certified
as a personal trainer
to learn about my body.
And that's when
I developed this system
that makes any workout
more efficient,
and it'll maximize
your result.
So I put it to the test,
and in three months' time,
I shredded my body
down to 4.3% body fat.
I healed
chronic lower back pain.
And then I developed...
Rodeo abs! Whoo-Hoo!
(laughter)
I then returned to rodeo
to win a national championship
in Dallas, Texas.
Now that's what
I'm talkin' about! Whoo!
(laughter)
Now let me show you
some of my clients
that got amazing results.
Here's Ray.
At 52 years old...
Kevin!
(laughter)
At 52 years old, he started
working out for the first time.
I taught him my system,
and in ten months' time,
this is what he did
with only three workouts a week.
Look at that.
Nice.
Now here's Shawn
he used to do 2-hour
extreme gym workouts.
He then got my system,
cut his workout time
literally in half,
and this is what Shawn did.
(laughter)
Look at that.
Wow.
So, sharks,
with your investment today,
I can get my lose 12 inches
with any 12 workouts
in the hands of the millions
of people who need it.
Whoo-Hoo!
That's what I'm talkin' about!
(laughter)
Who's ready
to ride with me?
You gotta tell us
more about it.
Yes, absolutely.
Thank you for asking.
What it is, is it's
a software program
that I developed.
You put in
your personal information,
and this calculates
your heart rate training zone
where you need to work out
during any workout.
And you wear
a heart rate monitor watch.
If your heart rate
gets too high,
you're gonna use muscles
for energy,
and you're gonna be
losing muscle,
and you'll never,
ever, ever
tap into your body fat.
It's all about
working out efficient.
So this simple program--
It's a trade secret.
And this is a dvd
that just educates people,
teaches them about
the heart rate training.
Why it's so important,
and what it does to your body.
Ryan...
so I work out all the time.
You need the system.
It's not working.
Because if I wasn't
in the gym every day,
I'd look like Mr. O'Leary.
(laughs)
But I don't look like you.
They don't look real.
Yeah.
I mean, your abs,
I've never seen--
Thank you.
It's like
the incredible hulk.
Well, and here's
what's really crazy--
in March,
I'll be 41 years old.
I'm literally
in the shape of my life,
and I've never worked out
so smart and efficient.
So what do I do?
It's so simple.
What you're gonna do,
Robert--
You're gonna put
this watch on.
A heart rate monitor?
Heart rate monitor watch.
The secret is, is me teaching
you how to use the watch.
When I buy
my heart rate monitor,
they tell me I gotta get
my heart rate above 140.
But it doesn't give you
a precise scientific program
that tells you
your exact zones.
So is it tailored
towards me?
Yes. It's all about the zone.
(Lori)
if I'm understanding right,
it's not like
you put in a disc,
and then you've got
an exercise routine to follow.
No. This--
This all has to do
with the heart rate
and whatever
you've figured out?
Absolutely.
You'll go do
your hour of elliptical,
and whatever--Whatever workout
that you may do,
and you're just gonna
stay in your zone.
(Robert)
Tell me your plan.
Yes. Step one would be
internet--
for $9.95,
they could download this.
They're gonna instantly learn
how the system works.
Step two that I see--
Get me on tv.
Get me in front
of the viewer.
You're talking
infomercial here.
Absolutely.
Infomercial...
he's the thighmaster cowboy.
Tv sales...
Yee-Haw!
Yeah, I mean,
you've got the personality.
Thank you.
It's great.
But there's one thing you've
gotta be really careful about
on tv,
and that is false claim.
It says right there--
"Lose 12 inches
with any 12 workouts."
Whether or not
the system works or not
is something that really
has to be validated, proven.
You have to have
an independent lab that shows
that you really actually lose
weight by doing this system.
(Kevin) None of this
makes any money.
I think what cowboy Ryan's
saying is,
"look, I'm a guy that you put
into an infomercial.
"I can go crazy
bouncing off the ceiling.
It's fun to watch."
I agree.
But what am I selling them
afterwards?
How do I make money.
Well, cowboy Ryan,
there's the challenge.
Yes.
That brings up
my next point.
This is phase one--
Teach people
the heart-Rate training--
Work out smart.
Phase two is my complete
Motivational dvd system.
And I have a lot more products
that--that I've developed.
So I patented a machine,
I used it,
developed my abs,
healed my back.
I licensed it to a company
earlier this year.
So are you ready?
Check this out right here.
And you'll never guess
the name of it.
Rodeo abs!
Yeah! Right there.
That's the machine
I developed.
The reason it is so unique
and so proficient
is because my patented
rolling wheel technology--
What this does--
You just sit on it,
you just put your feet on it,
and you just pull your feet
up and down just like that.
What are the handles for?
Oh, great question.
Those are the reins for when
you're riding your horse--
Hyah, hyah. Just kidding.
(laughter)
I had ya.
It's a full-body machine,
'Kay?
Arm curls, upper back,
lats.
Everything's different now.
Now you're startin' to want
to ride with me, aren't ya?
Can I sit on it and try it?
Yeah, absolutely.
I just wanna see.
And by working
your hamstrings,
you know what
it does, ladies? Watch...
(Wolf-Whistles)
(laughs)
Now if you have tennis shoes on,
you'd pull up and down,
and you'd also
put pressure downward.
Do you feel it, Lori?
I do feel it.
I can't believe you waited
so long to show us this.
Did you make any money
off it?
Uh, yeah.
Sold in Australia
and Germany.
Did it sell well?
It did a little over
a million dollars.
Whoa.
You remind me of an artist
that needs a producer.
That's what I think
the analogy is.
Hmm.
That's a good analogy.
You have a tremendous amount
of energy.
But I don't see
the potential for me
to give you $120,000
and make it back.
But somewhere out there
is the right person for you.
But it's not me.
I'm out.
Thank you.
(Robert) Mark?
Ryan, I gotta tell you,
I'm guessing
you're a great trainer
because you've got
the personality for it.
But sometimes,
when the volume goes up
so high,
my skepticism meter
goes up so high.
I can't figure out
what you are.
And when
I can't figure it out...
that's--That's
a huge problem for me.
I... I'm just not buying it
right now, Ryan.
I-I'm sure
you made a great rider.
But on the business
side of things,
I'm just not there,
so I'm out.
Thank you.
I-I can tell you, though,
this right here--
This is my blood,
sweat, and tears.
Hey, Ryan, did we ever explain
the 12 inches in 12 workouts?
No, sir, I didn't.
It's--It's all over
your body.
So I do a measurement
of your neck, shoulders, chest,
three measurements
on your abs,
your hips and your legs.
Oh, I see.
So I'm not losing
12 inches off my waist?
N--Particularly, no.
I've had a lot of clients
that definitely have.
But in ten years,
training 10,000 people,
I've never had one person
not lose the minimum
of 12 inches.
In how long a time?
12 workouts.
No way.
Yeah.
Yeah. Absolutely.
Ryan, I-I think your energy
is incredibly infectious.
All right?
Um, I am gonna challenge you
on the 12 inches in 12 workouts.
Oh, I'd love it.
I'd love it.
Maybe you're the next
cowboy Ryan infomercial king.
I don't know. But the business
you presented today,
I-I can't get there.
This right here,
and you're asking--
No, I-I hear you,
but, you know, I-I think
you've had a fair shot.
Sure.
I'm afraid I'm gonna
have to be out.
Thank you.
Sometimes the best cowboy
for the job is a cowgirl.
I love that saying, Lori.
I think potentially,
there's something great here.
Are you gonna be
his producer or not?
So...
♪♪
Three sharks are out.
Daymond and Lori
are Ryan's last shot at a deal.
Sometimes, the best cowboy
for the job is a cowgirl.
I love
that saying, Lori.
I think potentially,
there's something great here.
So...
are you gonna be
his producer or not?
Well, that's the problem.
I don't know that it would
be right to be your producer,
because I'm not sure
what we'd be selling people
would be the right thing.
And I always wanna give people
a quality product
that they're not gonna
be disappointed in.
Absolutely.
And this has got
a lot of claims.
Absolutely.
So for that reason...
No.
Hold on. Just wait.
(Lori chuckles)
Before
you throw the cowboy,
all I ask, and every person
that I've ever come across,
is you just
give me one chance.
A chance to be able
to change millions of lives.
I may be a little clouded,
but I'm gonna have to
just believe in my heart
and say
there is something here.
Just give me one chance.
You'll never forget the time
you invested in the cowboy.
Well, here's the thing--
You need to be able to prove
that this really works.
I'm not going
to invest today.
What if--what if I give you
more percentage of the company?
I'm here.
I want to negotiate.
I'm--I'm telling you,
I... I'm your guy.
I'm so sorry,
but I just see
too many challenges here.
And for that reason,
I can't be your cowgirl.
I'm out.
I-I do like it.
I-I think I like you more.
I think you're the--
You're the brand.
Ryan, I-I'm gonna give you
the $120,000 for 25%.
Really?
I'm gonna believe
in you. Yeah.
We're gonna ride together.
All right.
Whoo-Hoo-Hoo!
Let's go.
We're gonna ride together.
That's what I'm talkin' about!
I-I fell in love
with you, man.
Oh, my god! Aah!
I fell in love
with you, man.
Thank you.
All right.
I will make you proud.
I know you will.
Thank you so much.
Whoo-Hoo-Hoo!
Are you gonna look like that
in a year, Daymond?
I'm still trying to lose
my holiday weight.
Holiday '07, but...
(laughter)
(Kevin) Daymond,
why don't you explain
exactly what happened there?
You know, when he sat there
and told Lori
that no matter what,
he would bust his butt...
So you--your investment
was purely cowboy Ryan?
That's it?
Yes.
The guy is great.
♪♪
In season 3,
Raven Thomas sealed the deal
with Mark Cuban.
I'm ready
to say yes right now.
Done.
Wow.
For her Candy company
painted pretzel.
Let's see
what she's up to now.
(whispers) Yes!
♪♪
Business is going great
since "Shark Tank."
Before "Shark Tank,"
we had about $75,000
worth of sales.
Since "Shark Tank,"
we've almost exceeded $350,000.
Those look great.
The demand for our pretzels
is crazy.
I was drowning in orders
and making all the pretzels
by myself.
Now I've been able to move
into a professional facility
and hire a small team.
(popping)
I really love working
With Mark Cuban.
He's given great advice
and kept his promise.
Just the painted pretzel.
The painted pretzel is now
sold in landmark theaters,
just like he said
in the tank.
For my family,
the success after "Shark Tank"
Has meant financial freedom
and stability.
We get to spend
more quality time together
and less time worrying about
how we're gonna pay our bills.
Showing my kids that I can build
something from the bottom up
is the best reward.
♪♪
Next into the tank
are Mike Kane
and David Artuso,
offering a new kind
of protection
for a device
most people can't live without.
Hello, sharks.
My name is Mike Kane...
and I'm David Artuso.
We're from
Pittsburgh, Pennsylvania,
and we're the co-founders
of the cellhelmet brand.
And we're seeking
a $160,000 investment
for 20% equity in our company.
Cellhelmet
is the world's first
and only
brand of accessories
to include a safety net
of accidental damage coverage
for your mobile device.
You see, the biggest problem
with the mobile
protection industry
is you're forced
into ridiculous accessories
and ridiculous
monthly insurance premiums.
But when your device
does break,
you're either out of luck
because your case manufacturer
won't do a thing,
or you're pounded
with a hefty deductible.
(laughs)
First...
Let's take a look
at this bulky smartphone case.
This company goes as far
as telling me
that this case
can withstand abuse
from a boat anchor.
(clatter)
All aboard!
All right.
Ow!
Now Let's take a look
at these screen protectors.
This company goes as far
as telling me
that these are
"Military grade,"
and that they can withstand
abuse from rotary tools.
They better be,
or we just spent 20 bucks
on some plastic film.
(drills)
All right, guys,
as you can see...
(laughter)
Neither device
has survived.
You're facing
two issues now.
Number one--Your accessories
manufacturer is gonna say
you're crap out of luck,
'cause they could care less
that your device is damaged,
even though they told you
it probably would survive.
Number two--
Your insurance deductible
is gonna cost you
upwards of $200,
depending on your device
and your provider,
which doesn't sound fair
to me at all.
So now in comparison...
no!
Let's take a look
at the cellhelmet brand.
Are we saying
that our cellhelmet cases
can withstand all kinds
of crazy abuse?
Whoa.
Absolutely...
not.
(laughter)
If a cellhelmet case does fail
to protect your device,
we're gonna repair it
or replace it for 50 bucks.
Are we magicians?
Not at all.
We just happen to be
the only company on earth
who's bundling
our protective accessories
with a safety net
of accidental damage coverage.
With our hard work
and the help of the sharks,
we can lock down our own
massive niche in this market.
Team up with us today,
and let's change the way
people protect
their mobile devices.
Who's ready to join us?
(laughs)
So what you're offering here
is--is an insurance policy,
or a case, or both?
Basically what you're doing is--
Basically what we're doing
is pre-Buying your repair
in the instance that you should
have an accidental damage.
You buy the case
for $44.99,
and you register the case
within 30 days of purchasing it.
At that point, you now have
one year of a safety net.
If your phone accidentally
breaks inside of our case,
you're gonna call
our 24/7 hotline,
and it's gonna be repaired
or replaced
within three business days.
So you don't give me
another phone?
If we are unable
to repair the device,
we will replace
the device.
So walk me through the model--
How long you've been around?
We've been manufacturing
the cellhelmet case
for four months now.
And have you sold any?
We have sold 1,300 units
directly to the end consumer.
Oh, my goodness.
You guys are nothing burgers
in this space.
The guys who control this
do hundreds of millions of
dollars in distribution.
They just started
four months ago.
We've done about
$60,000 in revenue.
And what's it cost you
to repair?
Our average repair
for a smartpho--
Or for any device is $77.
But you're paying
for all that yourselves?
Yes. Uh, basically,
the way it works is--
Oh, I hate
your business model so much.
I have to punish you.
I just don't know how.
It's a profitable venture.
So do you know
what the attrition rate is?
Do you have any idea yet?
Yeah. Right now,
over the past four months,
we're averaging about 3%.
3% repair rate.
And the average is--
It costs you $77 a hit?
So let me
explain something to you--
That--We have that $45
when you purchase
that case up front.
There is a $50 repair fee,
so we're always
gonna be profitable.
Compare that to--
Sorry. So I buy the case,
I pay you $44.
Yeah.
But then if it breaks,
I call you up, and you say,
"give me 50 bucks."
(Lori) Yes.
There's--there's
a $50 handling fee.
So it's like a deductible?
That's a good way
of associating it.
Let me ask you this.
Let's say you have to
replace the phone.
Do you make any money
at that point?
Now you're out
$200, $300 bucks.
It's very hard to get
to the point of replacement.
Uh...
so if I broke my phone
using someone else's case,
then I went out and bought
your case for $44.95
thinking, "aha, I'm gonna pull
a quickie on these guys..."
there are people out there
that take advantage
of the system.
It's gonna happen
for eternity.
Uh, but basically,
the way our model works,
our average take is above
our average payout.
It's very fitting
that you wore those helmets.
Have you ever heard
of a viking funeral?
Uh, no, I...
they load up
a boat with wood.
(laughter)
They put the dead bodies
on the top.
They set it on fire and they
push it out into the ocean.
That's you guys.
This is a horrible idea.
I'm out
with extreme prejudice.
I wanna set you on fire
and float you out of the tank.
(laughter)
We appreciate your time.
Mike--Look, if you're
in the case business...
yes.
I'm not a big fan
of the cases.
Okay.
I think--So I don't think
you're in that business.
I think you're in
the "person who's afraid their
phone's gonna break" business.
So if that's
the business you're in,
I-I don't see the growth there.
If my phone breaks,
I just wanna walk in,
here you go,
give me a new one.
Um, I don't buy
into the strategy.
I'm out.
Yeah. Thank you
very much for your time.
Okay. Thank you.
I agree with Robert.
It's like you're in the, uh,
cell phone hospital business,
and I think it needs to be
cell phone emergency room
business,
which really
wouldn't be fast enough.
For that reason,
I'm out.
This, to me,
is really an insurance deal.
And I'm sorry there's so many
unethical people out there.
I think they're gonna
take advantage of it.
I'm out.
And four sharks are out.
There's only one left.
We got one left.
Guys, I get your business.
Definitely.
You guys are in
the arbitrage business--
You're in a business
of collecting money
and just hoping
to pay out less.
You're taking advantage
of the inefficiencies
of a market.
Yep.
Yes.
That sounds good,
but what happens
in that type of market
is that other people
with more money
figure it out very quickly.
So they'll see what type
of conversions you'll do,
and they'll say,
"if I only charge $25,
"and I triple what they're
spending in online marketing,
I can do the same thing."
This truly is a scenario
where big money can come in
and play the financial
aspect of this game,
because there are
no barriers to entry.
The number one thing
we do like about that idea
is when the big company
comes in
and does what we're doing,
that validates
what we're doing.
Bull crap.
Are you in or out, mark?
I'm out.
Thank you very much.
Sorry, guys.
Okay, sven and thor...
(laughter)
It's time for you
to get on the boat.
And it's with heavy heart
that I set it afire
and float it out of the tank.
Thank you, guys.
Appreciate your time.
Thanks, mark.
Thank you.
Thanks a lot.
Good luck.
Later.
I've always
wanted to break stuff.
Oh. (laughs)
(laughs)
I've gotta
send it in for repair.
(laughs)
I think that putting us
on the boat
and burning us right away
didn't really give us
an opportunity
to get everything out
that we needed to.
♪♪
Next up is Byron Young,
who believes he's sitting
on a great opportunity
for the sharks.
Hi, sharks.
My name is Byron Young.
My company is cordaroys.
I'm here seeking
a $200,000 investment
for 20% of my company.
Sharks, I'm here today to
show you the cordaroys beanbag
and demonstrate why
it is the most comfortable
and versatile chair
in the world.
Now first of all,
it's like sitting on a cloud.
There are absolutely
no pressure points,
'cause it cradles you
with super-soft foam
that's guaranteed
to never go flat.
But that's
just the beginning.
Check this out.
(unzips)
With cordaroys...
there's a bed inside.
(Lori) Ah.
Cool.
Sharks, I need your help
getting this amazing product
into every household,
apartment, and dorm...
(laughs)
in the U.S. and beyond.
My product is ready,
my company's ready,
and I'm ready.
Let's do this.
Can we feel it?
Absolutely.
I'm afraid if we sit in it,
we won't come out.
That's what everybody says.
You won't wanna get out,
but I'll get you out.
Just fall back
like you wanna make a dent.
What do you think?
It's nice.
Nice, huh?
Yeah.
Hop in the bed, Lori.
It's really... (laughs)
This one converts
to a king-size bed.
This is a full-size.
What's inside? Polyfill?
It's the same thing
that's in a sofa cushion,
except for it's shredded.
So it'll never go flat.
All the parts are replaceable.
The covers are washable.
Was it comfortable, Lori?
It--It's really
comfortable. It is.
So you're saying for $200,000,
I get 20% of your business.
Absolutely.
That means you're telling me
it's worth a million dollars.
Absolutely.
You know?
Or sales are so lucrative
that you're making at least
$200,000 of profit This year.
Both.
Oh.
We have a utility patent
on the idea.
The concept of the bed
coming out of the chair
is a utility patent.
Granted?
Not just a patent,
but we've enforced it twice
against companies much larger
than us, successfully.
Really?
Absolutely.
Good for you.
I like that story.
Absolutely.
Now let's talk
about the cash.
The cash.
Um, well, last year,
we only did $1.4 million
in sales.
Not bad.
(Robert) Wow.
And I say
"only $1.4 million"
Because my business
is designed
to be
a $5 million business.
I've got everything in place
from manufacturing,
products, personnel.
Um, we have a-a store
at the mall of America,
which has been in business
for almost eight years.
A store--Meaning
your retail store?
Our retail store,
selling only our products.
Okay.
All right. What was your net
from last year?
What was the profit?
The net was the problem,
because we're at
our critical mass.
And when I say
we did $1.4 million,
we only netted about
$100,000 last year.
That's fine. But have you sold
to any retailers?
We're in mostly
privately owned places now.
We have done qvc.
How did it do?
We did about $2,400
a minute,
and that was five days
prior to Christmas.
Is that good, Lori?
No.
It's not--I don't think
it is very good.
But you were five days
prior to Christmas,
which is a very hard time.
What year was that?
That's been
about ten years ago,
or eight years ago.
Oh.
So you've been
doing this forever.
(Lori) So that's, like,
a whole nother story.
I've been doing it
for a while.
How long you been doing it?
Uh, seriously
since about 2001.
You've been doing this now
for 11 years?
Yes.
(Kevin) seriously.
And you've done
about $1.4 million in sales.
Yes.
In--in the last year.
We've done up to--
Almost $3 million.
A year?
Yes.
And what is your cost
on that?
Uh, the--the queen,
for instance,
is sort of
our medium size.
We make it
for about 70 bucks,
and it sells for $259.
Yeah. Got it.
And we get--We have
40% margins on wholesale...
Yeah?
And 80% on retail.
Furniture in this country
is sold in some
pretty big furniture outlets.
And why aren't they
carrying them?
Because it takes a salesperson
to sell the product.
Oh, come on.
It's a beanbag.
I know, but you do need
to do the demonstration.
How much investment
have you made into it?
Well, I've got, uh,
$300,000 in inventory
right now
that's paid for in full.
I've got a $100,000
piece of machinery
that's specially designed by us
to manufacture this product--
Which, by the way,
is a very key part of this,
because we can manufacture
these very quickly.
Tell me what you did
in your web sales
in just the last year.
A little over
$700,000 last year.
Our customer is not technically
a beanbag customer.
You know, for instance,
our mall of America location,
they're all impulse buys.
Those people did not come
to the mall to buy a beanbag.
So what will you use
the money for?
I will use the money
mainly for marketing.
And frankly, I'm here
to find a strategic partner
who has already
done this with a product.
That becomes
a challenge for me,
because I just don't know
if I-I can give you
assistance in that area.
Mm-hmm.
If it was manufacturing
and production,
that'd be a different case,
but I think
you have that buttoned up.
Right.
Uh, so, I'm out.
Okay. All good.
I like what you're doing.
I think it's interesting.
But there's two issues--
One, it's very dependent
on you to go sell...
Mm-hmm.
Right?
And the other part is,
it's--It's geared
towards impulse buys.
Okay.
And neither one of those
really benefits
from more spending.
And you wanna spend
the money on marketing.
And so I don't see that
necessarily as--As a great fit.
So for that reason,
I'm out.
Hate to see it, Mark.
Hate to see it.
For $200,000 I get 20%?
You're telling me
it's a million dollars.
I don't think so.
I think your company's
worth about four or five times
what you made This year,
which is about 500 grand.
You're not worth
a million bucks.
Yes, I am. The company's worth
more than a million dollars.
Well, we can disagree...
well...
but it's my money.
So I think you came in
With too high a price.
I could adjust it
and go for 50%,
but I don't think
I'm gonna do it.
I'm out.
Okay.
So how many we have left?
Just two?
Come on. This is
a great deal here.
Somebody better
jump on it. Come on.
All right. Let me tell you
where--where I'm at.
I-I mean I think it's obvious
you--You--You need somebody
like a Lori for this thing.
Um, but I wanna be involved.
I'll give you $200,000 for 40%.
But I'll put up the $100,000
if you can convince Lori to
come in for the other $100,000.
What do you think, Lori?
Talk to me.
(laughs)
Come on.
Women love this product.
I don't want a partner
on this.
You know, aero beds are
a multi-billion-dollar business.
Mm-hmm. Right.
And they don't have a chair.
So there's a need.
It might do good on qvc.
Mm-hmm.
I'm not sure
about the price point.
So I'm gonna give you
a tough offer.
Okay.
But I'm gonna say first
that an opportunity like
what I'm going to give you
is going to come
once in a lifetime...
Mm-hmm.
And it's going to come fast.
Okay.
And if you blink,
it may go away.
Fast like a train
right over your head.
Ooh! Let's hear
your bloodsucking offer.
You know
this isn't gonna be good.
So...
I will give you
the $200,000...
Okay.
But I want 60%
of the company.
Wow!
Whoa.
Ooh.
♪♪
Three sharks are out,
and Robert's made an offer
to go in with Lori...
but she's made an offer
of her own.
I will give you
the $200,000...
okay.
But I want 60%
of the company.
Wow!
Whoa.
Ooh.
60%?
Because you're tired,
you don't wanna do--
You can't run around
and do all the work. I can.
She's trying to grab you
by the beanbags on that one.
And I can get it out there
fast and furious.
She's obviously
a very, very greedy shark.
She hasn't eaten today.
She smells blood in the water.
(laughs)
Um...
I'm out.
Oh, really? Okay.
So--So this is it.
Well, 'cause you couldn't
talk her into my deal.
I made my own deal.
Just so--To be clear here,
you realize that
she's put a value on you
that's less than half
of what you asked for?
I know.
I know. So you wanna
control the company?
I do.
Could you at least
tell me what the plan is?
The plan would be
to do our best
to blitz it everywhere.
To get it out,
get it on qvc,
get it into retail stores.
Possibly an infomercial.
Try to get it to be seen
fast and furious.
I mean, that's what I do.
I don't think I can
go this long with the company
and give you control.
I really wanna work with you.
I really do.
Counter.
I think it would be great.
But I think we've got a--
I-I have to maintain
control of the company.
(Mark) put a--
put a contingency on her.
If she gets sales
to $20 million,
you'll give her
the next 30%.
(laughs)
And if you do that,
I'm out.
So I can't give you control
of the company, obviously.
I just can't do that.
So my counter would be
$200,000 for...
40%.
Exactly what
my offer was originally.
But I think that she's
the right person for the deal.
I really do. I also would
prefer to only have one partner.
Come on, Lori.
It's gonna be
too much work for me.
How do you figure?
That's the problem.
Because I know that I'll have to
do all the sales for it.
Hmm.
I just know, you know?
16 years of experience,
400 products later.
Give me a counter
to your first offer.
Cer--Certainly
you can do better than that.
Better than 60%?
Come on.
Better than 60.
Certainly you can
do better than 60.
58.
Ha!
(laughs)
(Robert) Like, really?
I--like, really.
I mean, this--This is what
I think it'll take.
I think I can
make you millions.
Mm-hmm.
I like you. I would like
working with you.
But I think it's going to take
an enormous amount of my time,
my connections, my energy
to get this
out there everywhere.
So are you saying
that if you do have control,
I have to work less?
Whoa!
Well...
Good--Good point.
Technically, you would
have to work less.
But you're gonna be
a partner,
'cause I don't go
into anything
without somebody
being a partner.
So at that point,
I've got your full staff,
and we've got all
the connections we need, and...
Yes.
Hmm.
Gotcha.
Can I trust you?
I have a reputation
for being extremely trustworthy,
honest, and ethical. So...
Okay.
51%?
(laughter)
No.
Who gets the 51?
It's... it's 58%,
$200,000.
Take it or leave it.
I came here to make a deal.
(claps hands) Let's do it.
Okay.
(Kevin) Wow.
Wow.
Oh.
Mnh.
Byron, what happened there?
I believe that
when the product sells
as many as we're gonna sell,
it's all gonna be worth it.
He believes in me.
I want the product
to succeed
and become a household name.
That's my goal.
If that happens,
everything else will work out.
Well, hopefully, your new boss
will help you do that.
(laughs)
(Mark) That's right.
Promise me?
Yes.
(Daymond) Yep. Congratulations.
I promise you
I will do my very best.
All right.
Thank you very much.
Congratulations, Byron.
Thanks.
Wow.
This man went through this
11 years,
and he gave it up
that easy.
It's fabulous.
This is a winner.
He's gonna be like,
"Lori, it's your company.
I quit. Send me my check."
You guys wanna come up
with an excuse
for why he did that.
I just wanted
to sit in a beanbag
that was once worth a million
and is now worth $400,000.
(Lori chuckles)
I really came here
to get a deal.
I was not leaving without a deal
if at all possible.
I would rather make, uh,
a little less money
and have--Work with
someone like Lori
than to not get the deal.